اشكاليه كبيره في
موضوع العماله الماهره في جمهوريه امان
الاتحاديه هذه الاشكاليه
تشكل احد اهم المشاكل الموجوده في المجتمع
الالماني هذا يرجع طبعا
لشيخوخه المجتمع الالماني
وعزوف الناس عن عزوف الشباب عن العمل في
مجتمع الالماني وقله الشباب ايضا تحاول
الحكومه ان تسد هذا النقص من دول من خارج
الاتحاد الاوروبي على راسها طبعا الهند
بنجلاديش وكازاخستان وطبعا في المقدمه
منها مصر والدول العربيه يهتم بالفعل
اقرار قانون جديد للعماله المهيره
المتخصصه في المانيا وهو قانون النقاط هو
قانون النقاط يكون يعني معايير معينه اذا
اتم الشخص هذه المعايير يحصل على نقاط
معينه يمكنه ان يحصل على تاشيره
هناك فرق كبير بين ملفين اللجوء وملفي
العماله الماهره يعني في ملف اللجوء على
سبيل المثال لا تختار المانيا من يلجا
اليها لكن هناك اشخاص عندهم مشاكل يعني
سياسيه عندهم حياتهم خطره في بلدهم بسبب
الحروب مثل ما حدث في سوريا او ما حدث في
اوكرانيا لكن طبعا في ملف العماله الماهره
هناك اختيار دقيق لما يحتاجه المجتمع
الالماني هناك وظائف معينه يتم تسهيل
الفصول فيها على تاشيره الى حد كبير مثل
التمريض على سبيل المثال الاطباء ومثل
المهندسين مهندسين
كما قلنا لا تستطيع المانيا ان تختار من
يلجا اليها لكنها يعني في معظم الاحيان
تكون يعني
مجبره ان تتلقى جميع طلبات اللجوء وان
تفحصها وان اذا كان الامر يستحق ان توافق
عليها
لكن في ملف العماله المهيره هناك اختيار
دقيق
للوظائف والمجلات التي يحتاجها المجتمع
الالماني التي بها نقص في المجتمع
الالماني
المانيا تقدم تسهيلات كبيره في ملف
العماله المتخصصه لان المجتمع الالماني
بالفعل يعني على المثال يحتاج الى هذه
التخصصات لكن في ملف اللجوء كما قلنا لا
تختار من يلجا اليها عاده يعني كثير من
الاحيان يكون الناس يعني غير مؤهلين
لحرفه ما في المجتمع الالماني اصلا ان
نقارن بين الملفين وهذا ملف قائم بذاته
وهذا ملف قائم بذاته هذا له قوانين وهذا
له قوانين هذا مرتبط بقوانين الاتحاد
الاوروبي الى شكل كبير الى حد كبير العمل
ماهرا مرتبط بالحاجه الفعليه للناس
المجتمع وبحجز المجتمع وحاجه القطاعات
الاقتصاديه في المجتمع لذلك تقدم المانيا
تسلا كبيره جدا
[موسيقى]
اليسار ترى ان هناك نقص كبير هناك تاثر
كبير في القطاعات الاقتصاديه والقطاعات
الصناعيه والقطاعات الرائده في المانيا
لذلك يرون ان نقص في هذا
في هذه المجالات الضروره ملحه حتى تتاثر
حياه الناس وحتى لا تتاثر صوره المال
الرائده في العالم ولا يهم من اي خلفيات
ياتي هؤلاء المهاجرين الجدد هؤلاء العماله
الجدد لكن طبعا هناك في احزاب اليمين ترى
ان هذا
يؤثر على
النسيج المجتمع وان هؤلاء الناس ياتون من
خلفيه لا تعترف به
بالقيم الالمانيه او ما يسمونها يعني
بالقيم الالمانيه